[Applause]
I am so happy to see you live and in
here or should I say pupsen I know
um we'll see how this goes we're knee
deep in puppies everybody the best and
you know you have that incredible rescue
dog Maverick that actually is one of the
books that you've written yes
[Applause]
he's so look how cute he is he's um the
best and it just opened up a whole world
of animal rescue for me which is so
amazing I'm so happy that you have these
all here and that they're available for
adoption is incredible
these are not sisters these are not
sisters well we were just talking in the
commercial break like uh you know you
are the mom of two daughters yeah and
your beautiful book that I read to my
daughters
um is about sisters it's good night's
sister it's so wonderful
when you were
you were like little did you ever sing
like I'm gonna be a New York Times
best-selling prolific writer no no never
I mean it's it's to me it just really
speaks to these subjects and how people
you know resonate with the topics that
I've been lucky enough to write about I
mean when it comes to this subject of
Sisterhood it's like it you know whether
that's in a friend that you've chosen to
be your life sister or if that's in your
blood whatever that looks like for you
is such a gift to be able to have that
and to be able to Foster that and
nurture that at a young age is so
important and connect with kids is
really fun now as a mom so it's so fun
so have you watched White Lotus I
watched the first season of White Lotus
I haven't watched the second one I
literally can't even get through
Yellowstone which is my favorite show my
favorite show in the world no like it's
a problem and I've only been able to get
through a couple episodes because with
my my youngest is eight months and I'm
like with a nap I have one hour and then
I can watch it and then you know and you
already have a right assistant yeah
ask you one last question as a single
woman I heard that you've met your
husband the wonderful my favorite human
just an absolute
person who put such goodness into the
world Chris Pratt yes
um where did you guys meet each other we
met each other at church I love that so
yeah it was very sweet but we didn't he
didn't like try and pick me up in church
everybody's always like how did that
happen that you were like in church
how'd that work now why not this one's a
troublemaker I know I heard that you
said you and your husband knew when you
guys met that you would fall in love and
you know you saw the future you would
get married all that stuff how did you
know what should I be looking for
you know who would love to find you
somebody my mother oh foreign
I love your mother so much no it's like
her her pride in life really loves loves
to be a Matchmaker and she will she will
do it well also I would trust your
mother I I she is quite the role model
in this world yeah
[Applause]
all right we've got um prizes to give
away and I want to thank Dan schachner
and the puppies the puppy bowls 19 airs
Sunday February 12th on Animal Planet
one of the best channels available for
humans we humans almost deserve don't
deserve dogs and yet we're so lucky
enough to have them and these dogs are
available for adoption through the muddy
paw rescue
[Applause]
you know what as we go to commercial
break just notice how they've all been
lulled into relaxation I'm very proud of
that we'll be right back
[Music]